well that's awesome ah I'm gonna talk
about my wife actually should be the
only person I probably talk about
tonight so here goes I met her when I
was 13 it's this crazy love story that
should be some movie that I can't make
right we was in this church group she
was like it's really gracious like woman
rd at thirteen and then I moved away and
I joined the army that's where ten years
i'm jumping out of an airplane I'm
really scared and I have this vision of
this girl that I haven't seen in 10
years and it's my future wife and it's a
very calming calming moments and a
really trying time fast forward again
she's now in New York we're kind of
writing letters back and forth i'm in
afghanistan and we slept really good to
know each other it's a really wonderful
way to meet her as an adult fast forward
again we have our first kiss at JFK
baggage claim we basically move riding
together and that's usually where i end
that story because it's it's just really
beautiful but the fact the matter is
that there's a lot more to that story
there's things that are embarrassing
there's hardships and there's a year
after i got to the army why didn't do
anything i sat in a room I was scared
and my wife supported us and it is
incredible she's the incredibly strong
woman see you right now
when when you use confidence in yourself
it's is the hard thing to gain back and
when you think that someone is so great
the way that I can she is you know it's
having someone like her think that
you're actually worth something it's
really wonderful you can pull you out of
that and I just I was gonna talk of
anybody got to talk about you you know I
mean I'd love you baby thank you so much